another year another apocalypse it's all
in a day's work for the umbrella academy
from alternate realities to alien
machines this is the ending of the
umbrella academy season 3 explained the
biggest addition to the third season of
the umbrella academy is the sparrow
academy due to their meddling in dallas
during the 60s the umbrellas have
accidentally created an alternate
timeline in which they were never
adopted and trained to save the world by
their father reginald hargreaves in
their place exists the sparrow academy a
more refined team consisting of mostly
different people the sparrows include
marcus fay alfonso jaime sloan
christopher and more shockingly an
alternate version of ben who is
distinctly crueler and meaner than the
familiar version which often serves as
klaus's ghostly moral compass the
sparrows very quickly showcase their
physical and tactical superiority to the
umbrellas in a grand and painful fashion
their powers include fey's ability to
conjure murderous crows sloan's gravity
manipulation and christopher's powers
that are all associated with the fact
that he is a sentient magical cube
throughout the season we learned that
despite their effectiveness as a team
the sparrows have plenty of their own
baggage it would seem regardless of
circumstances or name any child raised
in the hargreaves household ends up with
issues
one of the bigger developments in
between season two and three was elliot
page's gender transition in 2020 the
award-winning actor best known for juno
whippet and x-men days of future past
came out as transgender on social media
one side effect of this announcement was
speculation from fans and media outlets
regarding paige's portrayal of vanya on
the umbrella academy considering vanya's
intrical presence on the first two
seasons paige and netflix announced that
his transition would be reflected on the
series this change occurs very early on
in the season with vanya adopting a
shorter haircut and changing his name to
victor
love the haircut
victor's transition though initially
jarring for his family is met with a
heartwarming amount of acceptance and
support from victor's first moments on
screen the other characters have zero
issue using his preferred name and new
pronouns victor from his growing issues
with alison to his dealings with harlan
is truly one of the season's biggest
players this season definitely gave
paige a chance to shine in terms of his
acting which results in some truly
powerhouse scenes kudos to the writers
as they took a real-life development and
used it to further the narrative in a
logical and tasteful way
every season of the umbrella academy so
far has seen the umbrellas deal with a
world-ending apocalypse in which they
play an integral part this season proves
to be no exception as we are introduced
to the kugelblitz due to their arrival
in the new timeline the umbrella's
presence creates a powerful destructive
and ever-expanding black hole this
situation is made even more volatile by
the kugelblitz appearing in the basement
of the building currently known as the
sparrow academy and formerly known as
the umbrella academy further compounding
matters is the academy's android made
grace worshipping the kugelblitz under
the mistaken assumption that it's some
kind of guy grace
what is this thing
a miracle
five's digging eventually reveals that
the kugelblitz is the result of his
family's meddling with the time stream
causing a grandfather paradox the side
effect of this paradox is the birth of
the kugelblitz which first by first
begins wiping all living matter out of
the universe this begins with the
sparrow's leader marcus and then
continues to consume increasingly larger
swaths of animals and human beings by
the season's end the kugelblitz proves
to be the most destructive force
introduced in the series thus far
in season 3's first episode we are
introduced to a mysterious yet neurotic
old man with a briefcase of cassette
tapes these tapes contain various
soothing sounds and ambient noises
apparently designed to alleviate mental
strife of some kind this old man's
identity remains a mystery until partway
through the season when he arrives at
the hotel obsidian after the old man
saves the umbrellas from a sparrow
ambush killing two sparrows in the
process victor recognizes him as harlan
from season two we see that harlan the
son of victor's love interest [ __ ]
adopted victor's powers after victor
saved his life in the 1960s these powers
are shown to be just as powerful and
destructive as victor's abilities even
giving harlan the power to sense other
people's vibrations however accidentally
giving harlan powers in the past had an
unexpected and gruesome side effect on
the future unknowingly harlan created a
powerful psychic blast that caused
explosive brain hemorrhages and all of
the umbrellas respected mothers victor
reacts with horror upon discovering the
boy he helped save was the first domino
to fall in this chaotic new timeline
in a plot device straight out of a
douglas adams novel one of the stranger
environments introduced this season is
the white buffalo room during their
season-long stint at hotel obsidian the
umbrellas stumble across a strange room
this domicile in question is a bizarrely
lavish room complete with a white
buffalo head mounted on the wall
discovered by klaus and diego's son stan
the room soon reveals its hidden secrets
to the umbrellas the first secret is a
bright hidden tunnel that leads to
another major revelation a second
version of the hotel with altered
aesthetics and a sushi conveyor belt
additionally the other hotel obsidian
includes a lobby bell that when rung by
diego summons a samurai style guardian
who attacks him and lila anyone know
what that sign says yeah it says do not
ring the bell
this space in question is revealed to be
a portal to another realm that houses a
way to save the universe the room as
well as the hotel is later revealed to
be a key part in the machinations of
reginald hargreaves the white buffalo
room definitely serves its purpose as
one of season three's key mystery boxes
one of the season's many subplots
follows klaus who is often considered
the most dysfunctional umbrella sibling
which really says a lot at one point we
see in season one klaus was locked in a
mausoleum by reginald to test his
supernatural powers these powers include
the ability to talk to the dead as well
as conjure the deceased for brief spurts
of time much of klaus's growth in season
3 comes from his bizarre interactions
with this new timeline's version of
reginald his adoptive father after
confirming that reginald hasn't killed
his or the other umbrella crew's
biological mothers klaus seeks his
father's aid following another
unintentional trip to the afterlife
complete with an encounter with the
bicycle girl from season one klaus
realizes he's effectively immortal as a
thank you for helping him discreetly
ditch his medications reginald opts to
help klaus test and hone his abilities
these tests include electrocution and a
game of father-son catch in which klaus
is repeatedly mowed down by oncoming
traffic in a delightfully morbid
sequence klaus learns to control his
powers it's this depraved father-son
bonding that allows klaus to help save
the day during the season finale
alison's gradual descent into darkness
proves to be one of the more intriguing
developments of the third season
following her arrival in the new
timeline alison quickly learns that
she's lost more than she originally
realized first she was forced to abandon
her loving husband raymond chestnut when
she returned to the present that alone
is a sizable emotional blow but alison
soon learns her daughter claire no
longer exists in the new timeline to put
it mildly this drop kicks alison into a
depressed state she externalizes through
a shorter haircut and darker attire she
even joins diego in a savage beatdown of
a room full of white supremacists to
help blow off steam however her biggest
dip into darkness arises when harlan
informs her of his mishap in the past
that killed her biological mother
realizing this new timeline including
her now non-existent daughter was his
fault alison kills harlan and delivers
his body to the sparrows desperate for a
return to her former life and some
semblance of happiness alison makes a
secret deal with reginald the details of
this deal are unclear until the events
of the season finale where it appears
that alison gets back everything she
lost
for the show's entire run we've yet to
get an answer to one of the biggest
questions surrounding the umbrella
academy just who is reginald hargreaves
the previous two seasons have given us
brief glimpses and teases of an answer
and season three is no exception that's
surprising i figured he'd know more
about his plan
sorry what's that supposed to mean
in season two we are shown only a taste
of what appears to be reginald's
sickening true form that of an
extraterrestrial here we still don't get
much in terms of a concrete answer but
we are given some definite major
developments firstly we learn that
reginald truly sees the umbrellas and
the sparrows as disposable means to an
end not only does he use his alien
biology to cut through luthor like a hot
knife through butter but he leaves klaus
to perish in the kugelblitz as well this
all is shown to be in pursuit of some
form of universe saving secret hidden in
the white buffalo rooms portal noting a
series of repeating shapes and symbols
five soon realizes the key to this
secret is built into the alternate
hotel's lobby seven of the umbrellas and
sparrows serve as sigils to activate
some form of alien machine allison after
realizing this will kill her siblings
opts to cleave reginald's head in two
revealing part of his true alien form
the show's third year comes to an end in
grave fashion by way of its craziest
season finale to date after allison
takes out reginald she still looks to
activate the alien machine despite her
siblings protests victor almost stops
her with his powers until alison
tearfully asks him to trust her allowing
her to push the button the scene
glitches to black and we pick back up on
the previous scene of allison entering
her home only this time not only does
her daughter claire still exist but her
husband raymond is there as well the
rest of the remaining umbrellas and
sparrows including a resurrected luther
and klaus emerge from an elevator upon
realizing all of their powers and
abilities were gone the group decides to
split up as they all clearly desire
different things luther goes off to find
his now missing wife sloane whereas
diego and lila go off to live their
lives the rest follow suit wandering off
into the night leaving victor alone to
tell off a statue of reginald before
walking off we then zoom out to see the
whole city is decked out in hargreaves
branding completely controlled by
reginald the season then cuts to black
on reginald and his wife previously seen
frozen on the moon overlooking what
appears to be their empire it's
definitely a mind-boggling conclusion to
the craziest chapter of the umbrella
academy so far and one can only wonder
what season four will have in store
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you